Después de cinco años de ser arrestados
se hizo el primer juicio contra Sara
mardini Shan binder y más de 20
activistas la justicia de los procesada
por haber rescatado a decenas de
migrantes en el mar Mediterráneo y
ayudarlos a llegar con vida a las costas
griegas el tribunal de apelaciones de
Grecia descartó las acusaciones de
espionaje el 13 de enero diciendo que
eran muy vagas pero los activistas
todavía enfrentan cargos por delitos
graves la judicialización en lesbos es
el mayor caso de criminalización de la
solidaridad en Europa según dijo
textualmente el parlamento europeo y hoy
en directo América nos acompaña
chambinder uno de los protagonistas
directos de esta historia Muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en France 24
es un placer hablar con usted su caso y
el de Sara mardini ha sido reconocido
internacionalmente usted es un alemán
experto en buceo de profundidad
es una Siria que emigró en una
embarcación desde Turquía hacia Grecia
en 2015 junto a su hermana jusra quien
luego fue campeona olímpica y la
historia de ellas dos fue retratada
precisamente en un documental o en una
película que está en Netflix cuéntenos
como usted conoció a Sara y que fue lo
primero que pasó cuando los arrestaron
en agosto de 2018
pero conocí a Sara cuando estaba de
voluntario con una organización pequeña
de rescate y búsqueda y en Grecia y
aparte de esta organización cuando yo no
emite Y ambos acordamos estar por más
tiempo del que pretendemos porque nos
estaba yendo bien y porque estábamos
trabajando muy bien juntos en búsqueda y
rescate
resultó que la primera noche que
estábamos haciendo algo llamado un turno
nocturno que significa estar en la costa
justo en medio de la noche mirándose al
Mario escuchando sonidos gritos o ver
humo o Escuchar bueno motores la policía
llegó y nos arrestó nos arrestaron sin
tener muy claro porque nos estaban
arrestando
para hacernos preguntas tomaron nuestras
huellas nuestros teléfonos y nos
mantuvieron hacerlo en una celda dos
días
pendientes de cualquier investigación
fue filtrada al público a los medios que
decía que un espía alemán supuestamente
yo y su cómplice Siria supuestamente
fueron atrapados en un Jeep militar
robado tratando de infiltrarse uno hace
y robar secretos mi primera reacción fue
como que esto tenía que ser una broma y
me pareció hasta bastante cool hasta que
entendí que era exactamente
lo que bueno la fiscalía nos acusaba y
era un crimen bastante serio pasamos
tres meses y medio en prisión ya por eso
bueno y precisamente en esta acusación
seria que ha seguido desde entonces ha
habido unos vacíos jurídicos como los ha
denominado organizaciones como Human
Rights watch por ejemplo esta
organización dice que cuando Sara
intentó Ingresar a Grecia desde Alemania
no la dejaron ir a la única audiencia y
también a ustedes los están acusando de
ayudar a migrantes en fechas en las que
no estaban ustedes en las costas griegas
que otros vacíos legales hay en el caso
de ustedes
hay muchísimos desafortunadamente De
hecho está vacía en general los cargos
principales que se supone que tengo son
facilitar la entrada ilegal Pero como
ustedes dicen yo enfrente de 12 pues 12
cargos de eso y nunca estuve en Grecia
por la vasta mayoría de esos casos y
para los que estuve estando en la isla
de lesbos durante la búsqueda de rescate
puedo comprobarlo utilizando la
evidencia de la fiscalía que de hecho
comuniqué cada vez como debía hacerlo
incluso de manera legal no tiene ningún
sentido ellos admiten que a las personas
que ayudamos eran buscadores de asilo y
legalmente los buscadores de asilo están
exentos de una entrada legal Entonces no
se puede ayudar ilegalmente alguien que
está exento de una entrada ilegal por
entrar ilegalmente Si suena que no tiene
sentido es porque no tiene sentido la
fiscalía
más o menos ha construido un caso entero
alrededor de falsedades e inconsi
ahora a Otro aspecto legal Y es que en
2019 y 2020 Grecia fortaleció las leyes
y las cambió para ir un poco en contra
de las ongs internacionales que ayudan a
los migrantes Cómo afectaron estas
legislaciones griegas a las ongs y sobre
todo a las personas que estaban
intentando encontrar un asilo en Europa
Temo que no entendí mucho de la
Traducción Le quiero preguntar de nuevo
Grecia introdujo los cambios en las
leyes entre 2019 y 2020 para limitar las
operaciones de las ongs internacionales
que ayudan a los migrantes como impacto
esto a las ongs y a los migrantes
Bueno estamos viendo que esto sucede no
solamente en Grecia como dices hay unos
sistemas de registro que tratan de
limitar el trabajo de organización de
búsqueda y rescate pero realmente a
través de Europa hemos visto un cambio
de narrativo un cambio de políticas
hemos pasado de una política como
debería ser de ayudar a las personas que
están en riesgo de ahogarse a políticas
nuevas de ver todo este tema como como
si fueran criminales y impedirles que
busquen asilo la verdad fundamental
sigue siendo la misma por supuesto el
estado de derecho cada
convención marítima internacional la
convención de Derechos Humanos la
declaración internacional todas son
bastante a favor sin ninguna ambigüedad
de ayudar a gente que necesita ayuda
proteger personas que están pidiendo
qué tanto ha afectado este sistema de
judicializar a las personas que ayudan a
los migrantes Y cómo esto ha afectado
precisamente a las personas que buscan
asilo
creo que el problema núcleo que estamos
viendo con casos como el mío
desafortunadamente yo no soy realmente
especial solamente uno de muchos casos
de criminalización no solamente en
Grecia sino en toda la Unión Europea el
impacto de la fiscalía
junto a los impactos de los protocolos
de registro significan que ha habido un
efecto bastante grave en la búsqueda no
hay civiles que están dedicados a los
que rescate
en la parte del Mediterráneo al menos
donde yo estaba ninguno eso significa
fundamentalmente que este viaje es mucho
más peligroso
el viaje requerido la necesidad de
observar los derechos
de la gente que busca que busca decirlo
se ha hecho cada vez más peligroso
porque no hay nadie presente esto
entonces son las consecuencias de que no
haya estas personas como ustedes para
ayudar a los migrantes pero Pero por
otro lado Europa también ha fortalecido
las devoluciones en caliente en las
fronteras y también ha hecho pactos con
países de África y de medio oriente para
que estos países traten la migración en
sus propios territorios Cuáles son las
consecuencias de estas dos políticas
bueno estas políticas están básicamente
diseñadas para impedir que la gente
llegue a Europa a buscar al cielo la
razón principal la motivación que la
Unión Europea da es que quieren detener
el tráfico de personas Cuando hacemos
tratos con países como Bolivia por
ejemplo
o cuando hablas de la Unión Europea de
Libia ese trato creamos un mercado para
el tráfico de personas Lo mismo sucede
en los países fronterizos en los hechos
son claros los conflictos existe la
gente buscará asilos con el fin de
Buscar asilos hay que estar en el
territorio de este país queda la
bienvenida aseguramos las fronteras
desde 2015 aseguramos nuestra fronteras
de gente que está llegando ahí
perros de ataque hay alambre de Púas Y
eso solamente significa un resultado
significa que estamos forzando a las
personas la política europeas que tratan
de tener este tráfico de personas
fuerzan a las personas a los buscadores
de asilo en las manos de Los Traficantes
de personas Ese es el resultado este
tipo de tratos son contraproducentes
para la perspectiva de los Derechos
Humanos del Estado de derecho pero
también desde la contra al tráfico de
personas y por último muy brevemente
Cuál es la situación en la que están en
este momento tanto usted como Sara
mardini
Face todavía estamos enfrentando
20 años de prisión si somos hallados
culpables de algunos de los crímenes Que
bueno que se nos han atribuido
enfrentaremos una sentencia de más de
200 años y ya hemos pasado tres meses y
medio pero lo realmente aterrador Es que
no tengo miedo de volver a la cárcel
tengo miedo del retraso hasta el juicio
podríamos estar esperando hasta 2038
hasta que esto vaya a juicio todo lo que
queremos es justicia todo lo que
queremos en nuestro día la